in this video I want to talk a little
bit about purine and pyrimidine
nucleotides biosynthesis basically how
our purine and pyrimidine nucleotides
made so where did that does that even
happen where are they made they're made
in the cell the cell cytosol okay so the
cytoplasm of the cell
okay and one important molecule involved
in the synthesis of purines and
pyrimidines hides is PRPP which is short
for five phospho ribose so one pyro
phosphate so the PRPP comes from those
things I just underlined so what is prpp
it's an important precursor in the
synthesis of those nucleotides and it's
also important in the synthesis of some
amino acids as well but we're not going
to focus on that in this video
PRPP is made from ribose 5-phosphate and
that should be familiar we're happy
we're just ribose 5-phosphate from where
have we seen it before well in a
previous video if you recall we talked
about it being one of the products of
the pentose phosphate pathway pentose
phosphate pathway and we mentioned that
that the ribose 5-phosphate was
important in nucleotide synthesis and so
here we're talking about exactly how how
that's happening okay so ribose
5-phosphate gets an ATP attached to it
and that yields an EMP and the PRPP
which were you know considering so that
reaction is catalyzed by ribose
phosphate pyrophosphate kinase oops
pyro phospho kinase okay so it's using
an ATP to add a pyrophosphate to the
ribose ribose phosphate which makes that
make sense so ribose phosphate
pyrophosphate kinase so this is the
ribose phosphate and we're adding a
pyrophosphate of pyro phosphate group to
it from ATP
hence the kinase term there so then we
get this PRPP so this is this molecule
here is actually what PRPP looks like
so we have the phospho ribose right
comes from the r5 P which is why they're
sort of in the same shade of blue here
and this pyrophosphate comes from ATP
the red right so we have a pyro of five
phospho ribose and then a pyrophosphate
so that's what prpp is now what does PRP
p actually do and why is it important at
the synth in the synthesis of purine and
pyrimidine nucleotides well it provides
the phospho ribose unit for both the
purine and pyrimidine nucleotides so
this portion here right this portion
here that we're talking about this
portion is important for this in decide
synthesis of purines and pyrimidines
right so this is the the you know the
pentose sugar portion and the phosphate
portion for those nucleotides so that's
what prpp does it provides this portion
for those nucleotides so how does it do
it
how does PRP we do do that for purines
specifically so for purines
prpp is involved in a long pathway with
many steps and what's important
essentially is that PRPP is the
precursor for this thing called inosine
5 prime mono phosphate which I've
actually drawn here I've cut off a
little bit of it there you go this is
inosine 5 prime mono phosphate or iymp
so this that it's like a nuclear excuse
me a nitrogenous base portion up here
attached to our ribose with with one
phosphate group I didn't draw that whole
portion but hopefully from the previous
video you can kind understand what this
means here so why is iymp important well
iymp is important because it's a
precursor specifically for the purine
nucleotides which you should know as
guanosine and adenine or you can go on
I've seen an adenosine sorry so now i MP
can be used to to create the GMP or the
ANP and each of us this GMP can go on to
make GDP and gtp and the a MP can go on
and make ADP and ATP so both of these
pathways either way you go right either
way I'm a MP goes it's going to require
enter
okay so what would we use for energy in
either case so in the case of GTP and
ATP if you recall we've talked about
both of these molecules being used for
energy before ATP almost everyone knows
that ATP is the energy currency in a
Cell we all know this right GTP is the
lesser known but still so it's still a
common use of energy right gtp can you
use much in the same way that ATP for
energy and if you recall we produce a
gtp in the TCA cycle so if we want to
create GTP and we need to an energy a
form of energy to power that production
are we going to use GTP well probably
not right if we're going to make GTP why
do we use GTP that wouldn't make any
sort of sense you can't use up what you
want to make that doesn't even make
sense right especially since if you're
making GTP it probably means you don't
have much around anyway right so you can
use GTP to make more GTP so in the case
up here what we would use is to make GTP
we would use ATP so ATP would power the
production of of GTP so this ATP will
turn into an a MP and a pyro phosphate
group okay
so that actually this this process
requires ATP energy on the flip side
though if we want to create a MP or ATP
then are we going to use ATP for energy
well know that again that wouldn't make
sense right if you're going to have ATP
and if you have ATP why would you make
more and if you don't have it how can
you use it to make it right that makes
no sense
you don't use what you want to make you
know to make what you want to make that
doesn't make any sense I'm sure that
might have confused some people but the
whole idea is if we want to make ATP
we're not going to use up ATP to make
ATP that would make any sense so the
energy form that we're using to power
the production of ATP is gtp in this
case so the gtp will can be converted to
a GDP and amount of phosphate exactly
why this ATP goes to an A MP and a
pyrophosphate this gtp goes to a GDP and
inorganic phosphate I'm not exactly sure
but I'm sure the pathways and
selves a little bit different so that's
the sort of general answer to that
question so does that make sense right
it should make sense because you want to
use a different energy form to make
another energy form it wouldn't make
sense to use one energy form to make
that same energy form so this entire
process of course is regulated tightly
why is that reason why is because we
don't want to waste energy obviously
right these processes require energy in
the form of GTP and ATP we also don't
want to waste nitrogen right these are
nucleotides filled with nitrogen we
don't know what be wasteful with that
nitrogen I just want to be as efficient
as possible especially since the waste
products of these purines is this this
molecule here and if you recall we've
covered that briefly
it's uric acid now your gasset is not
cool okay too much uric acid production
can lead to its deposition and joint so
in your like say like your elbow joint
your knee joint or even like your toe
joints just joints all over your body
right and that condition is called gout
you may have heard of it and that is
very painful okay so it makes sense that
you want to regulate a type this process
tightly so that you don't have too many
of this waste product especially if it's
going to accumulate in your joints and
cause you a great deal of pain okay so
that's a sort of general overview about
what goes on with purine nucleotide
biosynthesis but what about for
pyrimidine for per imitating the process
is a little bit different so in
pyrimidine we start off by producing
carbamoyl phosphate from bicarbonate
glutamine and some ATP so this is we're
producing carbon oil phosphate so in
hiss in this case we're going to have
this enzyme carbamoyl phosphate
synthetase which we've talked about in
the urea cycle but in that was carbon
mono phosphate synthetase one this one
is quad-band well phosphate synthase -
or CPS - so it's still making carbon
mono phosphate but in a slightly
different way and in this case it's
involved in pure pyramidal synthesis
so once we have this carbamoyl phosphate
what we're going to do is we're going to
take it and add it to this molecule here
what is this molecule here well this is
an amino acid that you should recognize
from the way it's drawn here it might be
a little bit tougher to recognize but
this is a part a specifically I'll put
here el aspartate okay now LS part a is
going to join carbamoyl phosphate and
produce this molecule here and this
molecule is called n carbamoyl el
aspartate excuse me so um so this
phosphate over here hops off and this
carbonyl portion gets attached to the LS
part eight here okay so now what
catalyzed that reaction that was a
reaction we actually excuse me that is
an enzyme that we've talked about before
it's called a tcas
or aspartate transcarbamoylase right and
we talked about that in a previous video
and we talked about the regulation of
that enzyme in the previous video so
check that out if you look for a TCH so
in the enzyme regulation video so check
it out so then once we have this n cop
mmol/l aspartate around we're going to
lose some water to form this bond here
to create to create actually let me be
specific there we're losing this h2 and
this oh here right and then we get this
this molecule here and this molecule is
called Diane hydro or I don't even know
how to pronounce this dye hydro Oh
rotate oh my goodness I have no idea how
to pronounce that but this is what it is
okay that's really not supported I'm not
really too concerned with the
pronunciation of this word but what's
important to understand is that notice
to what we're doing here is that we're
forming this ring and this ring is
basically the ring of the
that we talked about before so that's
what we're creating that's what we're
concerned with so this ring is created
and once that ring is created there are
a few more steps but later on PRPP comes
around to provide the phospho ribose
unit so then we create this here which
is if you recognize this base up here
this is uracil and this has a phosphate
group and a ribose so this is actually
you MP or uridine 5 prime mono phosphate
so this year LM pecan is a precursor to
UTP and from UTP you can actually create
CTP which is another parameter
nucleotide so how is this a little bit
different than purine synthesis well in
this case first the first thing that
happens is that the ring is built the
ring of the forum idiom is built and it
towards the end
prpp add the phospho ribose unit and
then we have our perimeter nucleotides
so I hope that general overview is
pretty helpful one last thing I have a
tutor if you live in Southern California
feel free to contact me via email at
Lucca University at gmail.com see the
description below for more details
thank you for watching